can i grow a beard i'm going to answer  that question in today's episode of ask  evan  so i recently got asked a question for  one of my super loyal youtube viewers  love you guys janie moon wrote in to ask  evan carmichael can you even grow a  beard can i grow a beard  of course i can  is this beard enough for you jenny  now i want to know if you can grow a  beard  so i've been growing this beard for  how long i don't know long long long for  this video  nina's not happy  but she's very happy that it's coming  off today  that's the highlight of her week  right i hate it so much actually  no  no  you get nothing with this  i get nothing janie i get nothing  because of you  okay  believe  bye